[Music]
everybody knows everybody knows a
[ __ ] mona lisa attack yeah the attack
on the mona lisa
a uh
man was dressed as an old lady in a
wheelchair wearing lipstick and a wig
pretty smart had a cake
maybe stashed in his purse or his pocket
didn't it just hit like a glass
well yeah so what he tried to do is he
came up and he tried to break the glass
because monalisa's behind this like
bulletproof glass or what the [ __ ] right
tried to break it failed it breaking out
obviously to weak out started wiping and
smearing it all over with cake with k is
the plan b
cake was cake was the plan a i think he
maybe thought he could break the glass
and actually ruin the mona lisa he
should have trained huh he was a weak
ass little baby do we have a photo of
what his disguise yes
this is the uh the mona lisa the cake is
on the glass it's not on the mona lisa
uh the mona lisa got steve aokid yep
where is he from
isn't he also french
the uh mona lisa is a girl
yeah we don't know their pronouns come
on guys
give her some credit okay okay
um the vandal
is a dude
here let me see let me see if i can find
that oh this is him it's hard to have
different perspectives on the show
because everyone just agrees you know we
have a different perspective yeah
and guess what we get alienated yeah we
yeah exactly we have we need to quiet
down yeah when we have lunch we eat by
ourselves exactly because we're like
yeah i believe all women i guess that's
controversial now yeah it's just an echo
chamber in here we don't believe all
women so here is uh
that's him walking out isn't that crazy
that like in if that was in la he would
be so [ __ ] up like they would have
roughed his [ __ ] up they would have dave
chappelle to that that's being walked
out they're not even touching him what
is the desire outcome of him just
throwing what he said is there are
people who are destroying the planet
that's why i did it that fool sounded
like he was telling me the menu of the
day and he was like we have the [ __ ]
special branzino we got doc over and i
was like listening
he's like we got french onion soup
french onions soup french bread and
french onion soup
and a little bit of french fries
three different ways
and cafe cafe that's what we have and
then maybe
[ __ ] you
the whole time i was like oh the special
of the day honestly when i heard that he
was dressed like a woman i was like yo
i'm going to [ __ ] listen to this [ __ ]
but then you know obviously
all women and then to find out that he
took advantage of this cause that
platform yeah that's what weaponized a
disguise bothers me to the core of my
being and as you know this side of the
table we can't stand for that and we
won't we won't and we're actually gonna
sit for it yeah do you think that was
metaphor too like he identified as
whatever he wanted to
to show to like i'm gonna stand for
something honestly i think this might be
a little harsh
but
they should execute him
the team style like a little bit like
old school france like honestly this
might be a little bit messy
this might be a little bit crazy but i
think this should kill his family
starting with whom starting with who
it's not crazy for me he's most loved
one because his cause and how he
executed it
just terrible i think there's a little
nuts anyone in a wheelchair should just
be gone now
are you including except women oh nice
but he was faking being a handicap he
was faking the handicap and being a
woman oh yeah okay so all handicapped
people should be off he's no no he's
this guy's being ableist he's being uh
sexist sexist he's probably parked in a
handy zone aegis he definitely parked in
a handy zone yeah
that's [ __ ] up but he identified as
all of those things so he's okay and for
those reasons i think he should be
executing i just can't believe he's
being escorted out like so gently versus
executed out so gently maybe because his
attacks were pretty whack like it failed
he failed at his disguise he failed at
his [ __ ] cake smear everything just
along the way was a [ __ ] failure can
i ask the most jk question that changes
nothing about anything yeah what kind of
cake was it
strawberry shortcake no it was a tres
leches
he went to mexico
no that's spain maybe he went to see he
could have went to just spain
probably like
he's like i need to trust leches i can
only get it in mexico it was just
moraine cake brothers can you look it up
and see
[Laughter]
that's gonna be the worst [ __ ]
that's the worst thing to ask the most
jk thing [ __ ] fault look it up real
quick rather than asking a question it's
worse to go can you look it up can you
look it up
was this they stopped looking at cat
like that asking her to do something
yeah
legendary
[Laughter]
these people am i right right all right
so no it wasn't it wasn't trust latches
i read it was i read it was when you
find it birthday cake it's a birthday
cake angel what is that angel's food
angel
yeah angel food cake
you really can say that i know i got it
i know it does it never gives you
specifics
that's
have you seen the mona lisa though it's
like i have
yeah it's like this small with the hyper
now you know why i didn't see it more
worth the hype than [ __ ] mount
rushmore yeah now rushmore you go there
you drive like 18 hours to south dakota
where the [ __ ] past 18 town i did that
[ __ ] went out there and then you're like
a mile away from it so it's like this
big no
i swear dude it was the most on our
founding fathers oh wait is that is that
because of the terrorism [ __ ] and
they were like you have to be way far
away because we don't want to get bombed
or something no i thought you're gonna
say something like after terrorism
sure though it looks like there's a
parking lot and you could just take a
[ __ ] photo with the mount rushmore
right now let's be real who wants to go
see that anyway you went to the
room who's who's driving i'm sorry
making fun of anthony no no no
right there
why don't you look up who wants to go do
that huh all right 18-hour drive it was
worth it
why would you do that yeah you're doing
a cross-country trip across america the
country is that the only thing north
dakota has or south korea did you go see
the grand canyon we did and antelope
canyon animal cam was actually my
favorite part of all of them
grand canyon i get all those canyons
yeah what the [ __ ] you know i'm not
going to go see that shoe and all that
[ __ ]
less people people [ __ ] piss me off
you know what i mean
new orleans is cool new orleans you know
the lube right so like everyone goes
there's a huge line around mona lisa but
all the paintings around that [ __ ] is
way [ __ ] better oh yeah they're
pretty it's way better and then i'm just
like these guys are just these
pretentious artists that are just like
everyone just goes oh my god have you
seen it yes i've seen it and then they
talk about it because they're just like
around the house but then there's like
sick ass wall art there's paintings that
are like the size of this whole wall
i'm just like dude that's some [ __ ]
quick and it looks like photographs if
you ever go to a [ __ ] museum in la
everything looks like they threw cake at
it
that modern art [ __ ] there's some
people that really want it with cake on
it
it probably is cake honestly it's
probably already an nft of like mona
lisa with the cake smear on it it's
probably someone ate cake and then
[ __ ] shat it out onto the wall does
anybody here know when picasso died
picasso picasso 1881
no i thought he died in the 70s yeah he
died in 1973. wait what wow you guys
know he was [ __ ] a very very
for the most part modern artist
no i did not yeah he was oh yeah i knew
that i knew that he was you knew that i
wish he lasted until 2020 so i could
tell him he sucks
damn i would have made imagine him
reading comments so you're saying you
wish he lasted until right before coded
dang he dies right before kovit he
thinks that the world is just still cool
just [ __ ] he has no idea your [ __ ]
heart is wow do you think he was like an
old school renaissance or the do most
people think it's a renaissance so many
people because when you study like you
think it's old raphael michelangelo da
vinci and all this [ __ ] hello
splinter
fred king
casey jones jones april and yeah o'neal
oh good so good crank crane was the best
artist
bebop
[Laughter]
[ __ ] collector's dog i'm telling you
dude but yeah incredible designers man
you tell me the mona lisa is dope look
at this [ __ ] these guys are the original
artist of the renaissance era i think
you're being freedom you know what i
can't wait to have you bro oh she
that's what it is you know what i
actually can't wait for it in like 300
years they'll have museums
and like you'll go and people were like
man i saw the charizard it was it was
smaller than i thought
very small nobody's gonna go see the
mona lisa no because they're [ __ ] not
touching history anymore yeah so they're
like dude the charizard i saw it it was
the original hall of fame it's [ __ ]
crazy shadowless [ __ ] insane but yeah
it's really small you think it's gonna
be really big it's really really really
small
it's gonna come in with some cake and
says there is [ __ ] global warming
do you think that [ __ ] works no like at
the nba [ __ ] finals or playoffs like
that when like those yeah those people
are trying to like they're sitting there
with like a referee jersey under their
regular t-shirt waiting for the perfect
moment to run on court in order to make
a stance for the environment like my
[ __ ] eyes dude through the hand on
the court properly they're like honestly
yeah i just have dry super glue on my
hand like people who retweet things and
they think they're doing something but
they don't actually [ __ ] get off the
couch and do anything hey hey they're
spreading awareness steve i'm sorry
you're just
with me right now bro you attacking me
what's his issue with the the
environment or whatever i don't think uh
it's if it's hot take time i don't think
that [ __ ] works it doesn't work because
it never [ __ ] works disclaimers on
that i'm gonna start using that if it's
hot take time well that's because i
believe that the global warming issue is
is a technological cultural issue yeah
and i think as long as you're not out
there inventing the new [ __ ] thing
you're not really helping like honestly
elon probably helped him more than
[ __ ] anybody else absolutely i think
like anyone who's in that like area of
tech or is the ones doing it like she's
trying something all the people that are
like trying to spread awareness are it's
just like a commenter going like invent
something already hurry up or like when
you drive down their neighborhood and
they just have a ukraine flag on their
door it's like okay
what are you doing
go fight the war then go over to ukraine
[ __ ] open the door grandma comes out
it's like my son just went over there
got killed and then you're like all
right
yeah then you're just like oh [ __ ] okay
i was wrong then you knock on the next
door with the ukrainian flag you're like
what about your son
what's your son doing no nick's like oh
he got killed huh sounds like he didn't
do that much to help the war did he
damn
it looks like he lost
[Laughter]
it's like dude nick goes up to a body
and he's like do something [ __ ] do
something
did you even help the war did you even
help the cause i think like asking
people to stop doing [ __ ] doesn't work
because you have to replace it with
something else so you can't be like guys
stop eating meat it's like fun replace
it with something else what i love is
going to make it out like eat worms
instead yeah i love going to anything no
matter what the [ __ ] it is and then
turning it into your stupid [ __ ]
cause it's like it's like i wish
everyone was watching what what's going
on that's horrible instead of this
stupid nba game right now and it's like
dude the reason why everyone's watching
the stupid nba game is because of the
horrible thing they want to [ __ ] tune
it out for this [ __ ] i think that i
think the only way to fix real problems
is to become a [ __ ] inside person
and
work your way up in the company that you
want to [ __ ] change you're lazy dude
and like become the ceo of the thing
that you want stop talking in idealisms
that make sense this is america yeah
come on bro everyone wants to go on
twitter facebook and just talk [ __ ] it
reminds me of occupy wall street where
yeah you're occupying the outside of the
building exactly like you could be
occupying the insides and be well you're
gonna [ __ ] play bongo drums and be
like hey we're the 99
it's like they're like they don't even
give a [ __ ] you're asking people to
change something that you could just be
those people and change it from the
inside out and then just be a [ __ ]
covert up this is what anthony does and
i i like doing this too he goes when
someone says a good point he does this
that's a hip-hop way of agreeing
when he's asking guys to come [ __ ] him
he does that too
why is that a thing you have to do like
that i like that too
[ __ ] me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me
i'm sorry anthony i'll show you i'm
trying to give you your flowers your
roses
yeah nick [ __ ] me [ __ ]
[Music]
now
[Music]